so the House Judiciary Committee has
started the process required to hold
Donald Trump's Attorney General William
bar in contempt so the first question is
what what does that mean what is what
does it mean to be held in contempt in
very simple terms contempt is when
somebody disobeys or ignores or
disrespects the authority of a duly
empowered body now oftentimes we talk
about being held in contempt of court
but it also applies to legislative
bodies and it's in this particular case
we're talking about Congress contempt of
Congress the House of Representatives
if you obstruct the legal work of
Congress which includes ignoring
subpoenas not providing documents this
can all be considered contempt of
Congress and that's exactly what
Democrats are alleging or will allege
that William bar did he failed to comply
with legal congressional subpoenas when
Congress requested the unredacted Robert
Muller report and William Bar didn't
provide it now this would just be step
one of the process of actually holding
Barr in contempt and I don't think
that's a process that will ever actually
be followed through to its full
conclusion and I'll explain that in a
moment but step one is for the committee
to vote on this tomorrow Wednesday now
it's important to know that even though
Barr released the redacted report the
unredacted report still has not been
released then chairman of the House
Judiciary Committee Jerry Nadler says
he'd consider postponing tomorrow's vote
on contempt against Barr if bar gives
them the full unredacted report no
indication right now that that's
actually going to happen but the most
interesting thing about this is not the
specifics of getting the unredacted
report I think they should have the
unredacted report the most interesting
thing about this is not whether Barr
will actually be held in contempt
because I don't think he will and I'll
tell you why in a second what's riveting
about this is that this is this contempt
of Congress charge was one of the three
things in the articles of impeachment
against Richard Nixon back in 1974 I
told you last week that Trump 2019 is
looking more
more like Nixon 1974 and yesterday on
the show I did a story outlining how the
difference between 2019 and 1974 isn't
that what Nixon did is worse than what
Trump has done it's that Republicans in
the 70s drew the line at abuses of power
of this level even by people in their
party Republicans in 2019 on the other
hand don't care about that they have no
such line so that is why this is so
interesting but to get back to the
contempt it self contempt of Congress
against the sitting Attorney General is
unlikely to ever actually be carried
fully out because when think - what
libertarians always talk about they say
the government is an initiator of force
because eventually men with guns will
come for you doesn't sound like taxation
is uh some kind of slavery under duress
well if you don't pay your taxes
eventually men with guns show up that
actually is a relevant thing to think
about when it comes to contempt of
Congress against William bar because if
the House Committee votes to hold Barr
in contempt and then the full house
votes to hold Barr in contempt and
everything else that has to follow from
that and happen to hold Barr in contempt
does happen at some point somebody has
to physically detain William Barr is the
house sergeant at arms going to
physically detain the Attorney General
very difficult to imagine that that's
going to happen is a court a court which
is of course part of the Justice
Department that William bar himself
oversees going to physically detain
William bar hard to imagine that that's
going to happen so the actual holding in
contempt of the Attorney General is more
symbolic than anything but the reason
why it matters is that this is another
one of these striking similarities to
Richard Nixon in 1974 and it is
political theater I mean it's political
theater in the sense that it's about
what it means to think about holding the
Attorney General in contempt rather than
actually trying to get the house
sergeant at arms to show up at the
Justice Department and say we're here
for the Attorney General because that is
very difficult to imagine it's going to
happen but it also represents
potentially the beginning or the
continuation of this exploding and
Trump's face we'll see how they vote
Wednesday in the House Judiciary that's
just step one and ultimately we'll see
if the unredacted Moeller report comes
out whether the full house ends up
taking this up and how this all impacts
the sort of particulars and logistics
but once again if we think about Trump
2019 Nixon 1974 you look at those three
articles of impeachment that were filed
against Nixon which ultimately didn't
remove him because Nixon saw the writing
on the wall and resigned in 1974 the
three things that were contained in the
articles of impeachment against Nixon in
74 are all things that the Moller report
provides evidence of Donald Trump
having done and once again again the
general atmosphere is contempt of
Congress by an attorney general gives us
another reminder of Nixon 1974 will
follow it for sure today's show was made
possible in part by better help.com /
Pakman better help is a service that
gives you unlimited remote access to
your own fully licensed therapist by way
of phone video and text it's less
expensive than physically going to see a
therapist in an office and you don't
need to have insurance to use better
help and they stand behind what they do
better help has a no-questions-asked
full money-back guarantee if you're not
satisfied with your experience all of
better helps counselors are thoroughly
vetted for accreditation and experience
it's all spelled out in their terms of
service
better help requires all of its
counselors to be fully trained and
licensed and they must have at least
three years and 2,000 hours of
counseling experience so you know that
your counselor is qualified to help you
but if you don't think your counselor is
the right fit for you better help makes
it easy to switch to a new one if you've
been thinking about getting involved
with a therapist you should really check
out better help just click the link on
underneath this video